black rod banging on the door of the
Commons Boris Johnson knocking on the
door of his brexit destiny the Prime
Minister looked visibly excited next to
a stony-faced opposition leader Jeremy
Corbyn as the two men made their way
through to the upper house to hear the
Queen read out Johnson's program of
reforms among a raft of new legislation
there is a singular priority my
government's priority is to deliver the
United Kingdom's departure from the
European Union on the 31st of January of
the 25 new bills listed in a speech
seven are related to delivering brexit
but the government intends to make the
most of its 80 seat majority there will
be the deepest review of Britain's
security defence and foreign policy
since the end of the Cold War the
Official Secrets Act and the laws on
treason will be reviewed and the
government will establish a constitution
democracy and human rights commission to
look at the very nature of how British
democracy operates it is a radical
program the Queen's role is over the
ceremonial here in Parliament has
finished and responsibility for enacting
this ambitious list of legislation now
falls to the MPs
back in the Commons the Prime Minister
was cheered by his back benches
I know call the Prime Minister
[Music]
but I say to the people of this country
we owe you we know it and we will
deliver and we have now the energy we
have the ideas we have the mandate we
have the people and we will spare no
effort to fulfill that mandate from
Scotland though a warning to the Prime
Minister Scottish National Party leader
Nicola Sturgeon publishing her own draft
legislation to start the process of
calling another Scottish independence
referendum
Sturgeon knows that the Prime Minister
will refuse to allow it a refusal she
intends to use in her favour for the
time being though Boris Johnson is on a
high fresh from a resounding election
win equipped with a big stable
parliamentary majority there is little
to stand in his way
Boris Johnson's last Queen's speech back
in October was also quite ambitious but
there was just no chance of him ever
being able to deliver any of the
policies there was more of a kind of
shop window for the forthcoming election
campaign as it was then
whereas now there is a sense that at
least at least in terms of the
parliamentary arithmetic he can actually
deliver these policies right the pace of
lawmaking will be hectic there is a lot
of legislation to pass in less than a
year to do an EU trade deal and
introduce a whole new point based
immigration system it seems an ambitious
timetable it may be that actually
enacting the new laws will be a bigger
challenge than actually passing them
Paul Brennan al Jazeera Westminster